hey the TAS are going to be giving a
lecture on concurrency and go basically
this lecture is going to be full of
design patterns and practical tips to
help you with the labs we're going to be
covering briefly the code memory model
the reading which we went over and then
spend most of the lecture talking about
concurrency primitives and go
concurrency patterns and go how you do
things that you will need to do in the
labs and then finally we'll talk through
some debugging tips and techniques and
show you some interesting tools that you
might want to use when debugging the
labs so very briefly on the go memory
model on the reading so why did we
assign this reading well the goal was to
give you some concrete examples of
correct ways to write threaded code and
go so the document like in the second
half of the document has some examples
of crack code and an incorrect code and
how it can go wrong so one thing you
might have noticed in the document is
early on it says if you need to read and
understand this you're being too clever
and we think that that's good advice so
focus on how to write correct code don't
focus way too much on the happens before
relation and being able to reason about
exactly why incorrect code is incorrect
like we don't really care we just want
to be able to write correct code and
call it a day
one question that came up in the lecture
questions was like talking about
goroutines in relation to performance
and so we just wanted to say that
goroutines and like in general
concurrency can be used for a couple
different reasons and the reason we use
concurrency in the labs is not
necessarily for performance like we're
not going for parallelism using multiple
cores on a single machine in order to be
able to do more work on the CPU
concurrency gets us something else
besides performance through parallelism
it can get us better expert Civet ii
like we want to write down some ideas
and it happens to be that writing down
code that uses threads is a clean way of
expressing those ideas and so the
takeaway from that is when you use
threads in lab 2 and Beyond don't try to
do fancy things you might do if you're
going for performance especially CPU
performance like we don't care to do
things like using fine-grained locking
or other techniques use basically write
code that's easy to reason about use big
locks to protect large critical sections
and just like don't worry about
performance in the sense of CPU
performance
so with that that's all we're going to
say about the memory model and spend
most of this lecture just talking about
go code and go concurrency patterns and
as we go through these examples feel
free to ask any questions about what's
on the screen or anything else you might
think about so I'm going to start off
talking about concurrency primitives and
go so the first thing is closures this
is something that will almost certainly
be helpful in the labs and this is
related to go routines so here's this
example program on the screen and what
it does is the main function declares a
bunch of variables and then spawns this
go routine in here with this go
statement and we noticed that the score
routine is not taking it as an argument
a function call to some function defined
elsewhere but this anonymous function
just defined in line here so this is a
handy pattern this is something called a
closure and one neat thing about this is
that this function that's defined here
can refer to variables from the
enclosing scope so for example this
function can mutate this variable a
that's defined up here or refer to this
weight group that's defined up here so
if we go run this example it does what
you think it does
the weight group dot done here let's the
main thread continue past this point it
prints out this variable which has been
mutated by this concurrently running
thread that finished before this weight
happened so this is a useful pattern to
be able to use one like the reason we're
pointing this out is because you might
have code that looks like this in your
labs very similar to the previous
example except this is code that is
spawning a bunch of threads in a loop
this is useful for example when you want
to send our pcs in parallel right so
like in lab two if you have a candidate
asking for votes you want to ask for
votes from all the followers in parallel
not one after the other because the RPC
is a blocking operation that might take
some time or similarly the leader might
want to send append entries to all the
followers you want to do it in parallel
not in series and so threads are a clean
way to express this idea and so you
might have code that looks kind of like
this at a high level in a for loop you
spawn a bunch of go routines one thing
to be careful about here this is
something that was talked about in a
previous lecture
is identifier capture and goroutines and
mutation of that identifier in the outer
scope so we see here that we have this
eye that's being mutated by this for
loop and then we want to use that value
inside the square root een and the way
we do that like the correct way of
writing this code is to pass this value
I as an argument to this function and
this function or you can rename it to X
inside here and then use the value
inside and so if we run this program
so here I've kind of stubbed out to send
our PC thing was actually just prints
out the index this I might be like the
index of the follower trying to send an
RPC to here prints out the numbers 0
through 4 in some order so this is what
we want like send our PCs to all the
followers the reason we're showing you
this code is because there's a variation
of this code which looks really similar
and maybe intuitively you might think it
does the right thing but in fact it
doesn't so in this code the only thing
that's changed is we've gotten rid of
this argument here that we're explicitly
passing and instead we're letting this I
refer to the eye from the outer scope so
you might think that when you run this
it does the same thing but in fact in
this particular run it printed 4 5 5 5 5
so this would do the wrong thing and the
reason for this is that this I is being
mutated by this outer scope and by the
time this go routine ends up actually
executing this line well the for loop
has already changed the value of I so
this doesn't do the right thing so at a
high level if you're spawning goroutines
in a loop just make sure that you use
this pattern here and everything will
work right any questions about that
so it's just like a small gotcha but
we've seen this a whole bunch of times
in office hours so I just wanted to
point this out all right so moving on to
other patterns that you might want to
use in your code oftentimes you want
code that periodically does something a
very simple way to do that is to have a
separate function that in an infinite
loop does something in this case we're
just printing out tick and then use this
time dot sleep to wait for a certain
amount of time so very simple pattern
here
you don't need anything fancier than
this to do something periodically
one modification of this that you might
want is you want to do something
periodically until something happens for
example you might want to start up a
raft here and then periodically send
heartbeats but when we call dot kill on
the raft instance you want to actually
shut down all these goroutines so you
don't have all these random goroutines
still running in the background and so
the pattern for that looks something
like this you have a goroutine that will
run in an infinite loop and do something
and then wait for a little bit and then
you can just have a shared variable
between whatever control thread is going
to decide whether this goroutine should
die or not so in this example we have
this variable done that's a global
variable and what main does is it waits
for awhile and sets done to true and in
this go routine that's ticking and doing
work periodically we're just checking
the value of done and if done is set
then we terminate the square-root eeen
and here since done is a shared variable
being mutated and read by multiple
threads we need to make sure that we
guard the use of this with a lock so
that's where this mute outlaw can mute
it unlock comes in for the purpose of
the labs you can actually write
something a little bit simpler than this
so we have this method RF killed on your
raft instance so you might have code
that looks a little bit more like this
so while you're wrapped instance is not
dead you want to periodically do some
work any questions about that so far
yeah question
does using the locking mechanisms for
channels make it so that any right
stunts any variables and those functions
are to be observed by the fencer would
you need to send done across the channel
okay so let me try to simplify the
question a bit I think the question is
do you need to use locks here can you
use channels instead and R and can you
get away with not using locks and like
what's the difference between nothing
versus channels vs locks is that
basically what you're asking I think the
question is this done does it not need
to be sent across a channel does just
using these locks ensure that this read
here observes the write done by a thread
okay so the answer is yes basically at a
high level if you want to ensure cross
thread communication make sure you use
go synchronization primitives whether
it's channels or locks and condition
variables and so here because of the use
of locks after this thread writes done
and does unlock the next lock that
happens is guaranteed to observe the
writes done before that before this
unlock happened so you have this write
happened and this unlock happened then
one of these locks happens and then the
next done will be guaranteed to observe
that write of true question
that's a good question in this
particular code it doesn't matter but it
would be cleaner to do it so the
question is why don't we do mu dot
unlock here before returning and the
answer is in here there's no more like
the program's done so it doesn't
actually end up mattering but you're
right that like in general we would want
to ensure that we unlock before we
return yeah thanks for pointing that out
so I'm not sure entirely what the
question is but maybe something like can
both of these acquire the lock at the
same time is that the question and we'll
talk a little bit more about locks in
just a moment but at a high level the
semantics of a lock are the lock is
either held by somebody or not held by
somebody and if it's not held by
somebody then if someone calls lock they
have the chance to acquire the lock and
if before they call unlock somebody else
calls lock that other thread is going to
be blocked until the unlock happens then
the lock is free again so at a high
level between the lock and the unlock
for any particular lock like any only a
single thread can be executing what's
called a critical section between the
lock and unlock regions any other
questions
so the question is related to timing
like when you set done equals true and
then you unlock you have no guarantee in
terms of real time like when periodic
will end up being scheduled and observe
this right and actually end up
terminating and so yes if you want to
mean to actually ensure that periodic
has exited for some particular reason
then you could write some code that
communicates back from periodic
acknowledging this but in this
particular case like the only reason we
have the sleep here is just to
demonstrate that the sleep here is just
to demonstrate that tick prints for a
while and then periodic as indeed cancel
it because it stops being printed before
I get my shell prompt back and in
general for a lot of these background
threads like you can just say that you
want to kill them and it doesn't matter
if they're killed within 1 second or
within 2 seconds or one exactly go
schedules it because this thread is
going to just observe this right to done
and then exit do no more works it
doesn't really matter and also another
thing in go is that if you spawn a bunch
of goo routines one of them is the main
go routine this one here and the way go
works is that if the main goroutine
exits the whole program terminates and
all go routines are terminated
that's a great question okay so I think
the question is something like why do
you need locks at all like can you just
delete all the locks and then like
looking at this code it looks like okay
main does a right to true at some point
and periodic is repeatedly reading it so
at some point it should observe this
read right well it turns out that like
this is why go has this fancy memory
model and you have this whole thing on
that happens before relation the
compiler is allowed to take this code
and emit a kind of low-level machine
code that does something a little bit
different than what you intuitively
thought would happen here and we can
talk about that in detail offline after
the lecture and office hours but at a
high level I think one rule you can
follow is if you have accesses to shared
variables and you want to be able to
observe them across different threads
you need to be holding a lock before you
read or write those shared variables in
this particular case I think the go
compiler would be allowed to optimize
this to like lift the read of done
outside the four so read this shared
variable once and then if done is false
then set like make the inside be an
infinite loop because like now the way
this thread is written it had uses no
synchronization primitives there's no
mutex lock or unlock no channel sends or
receives and so it's actually not
guaranteed to observe any mutations done
by other concurrently running threads
and if you look on Piazza I've actually
like written a particular go program
that is optimized in the unintuitive way
like it'll produce code that does an
infinite loop even though looking at it
like you might think that oh the obvious
way to compile this code will produce
something that terminates yeah so the
memory model is pretty fancy and it's
really hard to think about why exactly
incorrect programs are incorrect but if
you follow some general rules like whole
blocks before you mutate shared
variables then you can avoid thinking
about some of these nasty issues
any other questions all right so let's
talk a little bit more about mutexes now
so why do you need mutex is at a high
level whenever you have concurrent
access but by different threads to some
shared data you want to ensure that
reads and writes of that data are atomic
so here's one example of program that
declares a counter and then spawns a
goroutine
actually spawns a thousand go routines
that each update the counter value and
increment it by one and you might think
that looking at this intuitively when I
print out the value of the counter at
the end it should print a thousand but
it turns out that we missed some of the
updates here and in this particular case
it only printed 947 so what's going on
here is that this update here is not
really protected in any way and so these
threads running concurrently can read
the value of counter and update it and
clobber other threads updates of this
value like basically we want to ensure
that this entire section here happens
atomically and so the way you make
blocks of code run atomically are by
using locks and so in this code example
we've fixed this bug we create a lock
and then all these go routines that
modify this counter value first grab the
lock then update the counter value and
then unlock and we see that we're using
this defer keyword here what this does
is basically the same as putting this
code down here so we grab a lock do some
update then unlock defer is just a nice
way of remembering to do this you might
forget to write the unlock later and so
what defer does is it you can think of
it as like scheduling this to run at the
end of the current function body and so
this is a really common pattern you'll
see for example in your RPC handlers for
the lab so oftentimes RPC handlers will
manipulate either read or write data on
the RAF structure right and those
updates should be synchronized with
other concurrently happening updates and
so oftentimes the pattern for RPC
handles would be like grab the lock
differ unlock and then go do some work
inside so we can see if we run this code
it produces the expected results so it
prints out a thousand and we haven't
lost any of these updates and so what at
a high level what a lock or a mutex can
do is guarantee mutual exclusion for a
region of code which we call a critical
section so in here this is the critical
section and it ensures that none of
these critical sections execute
concurrently with
ones they're all serialized happened one
after another question
yes so this is a good observation this
particular could is actually not
guaranteed to produce a thousand
depending on how thread scheduling end
up ends up happening because all the
mean guru teen does is it waits for one
second which is some arbitrary unit of
time and then it prints out the value of
the counter I just want to keep this
example as simple as possible a
different way to write this code that
would be guaranteed to print a thousand
would be to have the main goroutine wait
for all these thousand threads to finish
so you could do this using a weight
group for example but we didn't want to
put two synchronization primitives like
weight groups and mutex is in the same
example so that's why we're at this code
that is like technically incorrect but I
think it still demonstrates the point of
locks any other questions great so at a
very high level you can think of locks
is like you grab the lock you mutate the
shared data and then you unlock so does
this pattern always work well turns out
that that's like a useful starting point
for how to think about locks but it's
not really the complete story so here's
some code this doesn't fit on the screen
but I'll explain it to you we can scroll
through it it basically implements a
bank at a high level so I have Alice and
Bob who both start out with some
balances and then I keep track of what
the total balances like the total amount
of money I store in my bank and then I'm
going to spawn to go routines that will
transfer money back and forth between
our Alice and Bob so this one girl
routine that a thousand times will
reduce one from Alice and send it to Bob
and concurrently running I have this
other go routine that in a loop will
reduce one from Bob and send it to Alice
and notice that I have this mutex here
and whenever I manipulate these shared
variables between these two different
threads
I'm always locking the mutex and this
update only happens while this lock is
held right and so is this code correct
or incorrect there actually isn't really
a straightforward answer to that
question it depends on like what are the
semantics of my bank like what behavior
do I expect so I'm going to introduce
another thread here I'll call this one
the audit thread and what this is going
to do is every once in a while I'll
check it check the sum of all the
accounts in my bank and make sure that
the sum is the same as what it started
out as
right click if I only allow transfers
within my bank the total amount should
never change so now given this other
thread so what this does is it grabs the
lock then sums up Alice Plus Bob and
compares it to the total and if it
doesn't match then it says that though
I've observed some violation that my
total is no longer what it should be if
I run this code I actually see that a
whole bunch of times
this concurrently running thread does
indeed observe that Alice Plus Bob is
not equal to the overall sum so what
went wrong here like we're following our
basic rule of whenever we're accessing
data that's shared between threads we
grab a lock it is indeed true that no
updates to these shared variables happen
while the lock is not held exactly so
let me repeat that for everybody to hear
what we intended here was for this
decrement and increment to happen
atomically but instead of what we ended
up writing was code that decrement
atomically and then increments
atomically and so in this particular
code actually like we won't lose money
in the long term like if we let these
threads run and then wait till they
finish and then check the total it will
indeed be what it started out as but
while these are running since this
entire block of code is not atomic we
can temporarily observe these violations
and so at a higher level the way should
think about locking is not just like
locks are to protect access to shared
data but locks are meant to protect
invariants you have some shared data
that multiple people might access and
there's some properties that hold on
that shared data like for example here I
is the programmer decided that I want
this property that alice + Bob should
equal some constant and that should
always be that way I want that property
to hold but then it may be the case that
different threads running concurrently
are making changes to this data and
might temporarily break this invariant
here right like here when I decrement
from Alice temporarily the sum Alice
Plus Bob has changed but then this
thread eventually ends up restoring this
invariant here and so locks are meant to
protect and vary
at a high level you grab a lock then you
do some work that might temporarily
break the invariant but then you restore
the invariant before you release the
lock so nobody can observe these in
progress updates and so the correct way
to write this code is to actually have
less use of lock and unlock
we have lock then we do a bunch of work
and then we unlock and when you run this
code we see no more printouts like this
that we never have this audit thread
observe that the total is not what it
should be all right so that's the right
way to think about locking at kind of a
high level you can think about it as
make sure you grab locks when every
access shared data like that is a rule
but another important rule is locks
protect invariants so grab a lock
manipulate things in a way that might
break the invariants but restore them
afterwards and then release the lock
another way you can think about it is
locks can make regions of code atomic
not just like single statements or
single updates to shared variables any
questions about that great so the next
synchronization primitive we're going to
talk about it something called condition
variables and this is it seems like
there's been a source of confusion from
lab one where we mentioned condition
variables but didn't quite explain them
so we're going to take the time to
explain them to you now and we're going
to do that in the context of an example
that you should all be familiar with
counting votes so remember in lab 2a you
have this pattern where whenever Raph
Pierre becomes a candidate it wants to
send out vote requests all of its
followers and eventually the followers
come back to the candidate and say yes
or no like whether or not the candidate
got the vote right and one way we could
write this code is have the candidate in
serial ask Pierre number one car number
two for number three and so on but
that's bad right because we want the
candidate ask all the peers in parallel
so it can quickly win the election when
possible and then there's some other
complexities there like when we ask all
the peers in parallel we don't want to
wait so we get a response from all of
them before making up our mind right
because if a candidate gets a majority
of votes like it doesn't need to wait
till it hears back from everybody else
so this code is kind of complicated in
some ways and so here here's a kind of
stubbed out version of what that vote
counting code might look like
with a little bit of infrastructure to
make it actually run and so here have
this mean goroutine that sets count
which is like the number of yes votes I
got to zero and finish to zero finished
as the number of responses I've gotten
in total and the idea is I want to send
out vote requests in parallel and keep
track of how many yeses I've got and how
many responses I've gotten in general
and then once I know whether I've won
the election or whether I know that I've
lost the election then I can determine
that and move on and like the real raft
code you actually do whatever you need
to do don't step up to a leader or to
step down to a follower after you have
the result from this and so looking at
this code here I'm going to in parallel
spun say I have ten peers in parallel
spawn ten goroutines
here I pass in this closure here and I'm
gonna do is request a vote and then if I
get the vote I'm going to increment the
count by one and then I'm also going to
increment this finished by one so like
this is a number of yeses this is total
number of responses I've gotten and then
outside here in the main go routine what
I'm doing is keeping track of this
condition I'm waiting for this condition
to become true that either I have enough
yes votes that I've won the election or
I've heard back from enough peers and I
know that I've lost and so I'm just
going to in a in a loop check to see and
wait until count is greater than or
equal to five or wait until finished is
equal to ten and then after that's the
case I can either determine that I've
lost drive one so does anybody see any
problems with this code given what we
just talked about about mutexes yes
yeah exactly
countin finished aren't protected by
mutexes so one thing we certainly need
to fix here is that whenever we have
shared variables we need to protect
access with new taxes and so that's not
too bad to fix here I declare mutex
that's accessible by everybody and then
in the go routines I'm launching in
parallel to request votes I'm going to
and this this pattern here is pretty
important I'm going to first request a
vote while I'm not holding the lock and
then after wear that I'm going to grab
the lock and then update these shared
variables and then outside I have the
same patterns as before except I make
sure to lock and unlock between reading
these shared variables so in an infinite
loop I grab the lock and check to see if
the results of the election have been
determined by this point and if not I'm
going to keep running in this infinite
loop otherwise I'll unlock and then do
what I need to do outside of here and so
if I run this example whoops it seems to
work and this is actually like a correct
implementation it does the right thing
but there's some problems with it so can
anybody recognize any problems with this
implementation I'll give you a hint this
code is not as nice as it could be
so not quite it's going to wait for
exactly the right amount of time the
issue here is that it's busy waiting
what it's doing is in a very tight loop
it's grabbing the lock checking this
condition unlocking grabbing this lock
checking this condition unlocking and
it's going to burn up 100% CPU on one
core while it's doing this so this code
is correct but it's like at a high level
we don't care about efficiency like CPU
efficiency for the purpose of the labs
but if you're using a hundred percent of
one core you might actually slow down
the rest of your program enough that it
won't make progress and so that's why
this pattern is bad that we're burning
up a hundred percent CPU waiting for
some condition to become true right so
does anybody have any ideas for how we
could fix this so here's one simple
solution
I will change a single line of code all
I've added here is wait for 50
milliseconds and so this is a correct
transformation of that program and it
kind of seems to solve the problem right
like before I was burning up a hundred
percent CPU now only once every 50
milliseconds I'm going to briefly wake
up check this condition and go back to
sleep
if it doesn't hold and so this is like
basically a working solution any
questions so this kind of sorta works
but one thing you should always be aware
of whenever you write code is magic
constants why is this 50 milliseconds
why not a different number like whenever
you have an arbitrary number in your
code it's a sign that you're doing
something that's not quite right or not
quite as clean as it could be and so it
turns out that there's a concurrency
primitive designed to solve exactly this
problem of I have some threads running
concurrently that are making updates to
some shared data and then I have another
thread that's waiting for some property
some condition on that shared data to
become true and until that condition
becomes true the thread is just going to
wait there's a tool designed exactly to
solve this problem and that's a tool
called a condition variable and the way
you use a condition variable is the
pattern basically looks like this so we
have our lock from earlier condition
variables are associated with locks so
we have some shared data some a lock
that protects that shared data and then
we have this condition variable that is
given a pointer to the lock when it's
initialized and we're going to use this
condition variable for kind of
coordinating when a certain condition
some property on that shared data when
that becomes true and the way we modify
our code is like we have two places one
we're making changes to that data which
might make the condition become true and
then we have another place where we're
waiting for that condition to become
true and the general pattern is whenever
we do something that changes the data we
call a conduct broadcast and we do this
while holding the lock and then on the
other side where we're waiting for some
condition on that share data to become
true we call con dot wait and so what
this does is like let's think about what
happens in the mean thread for a moment
the main thread grabs the lock it checks
this condition suppose it's false it
calls con dot wait what this will do is
it will atomically you can think of it
as it'll release the lock in order to
let other people make progress and it'll
add its thread like it'll add itself to
a like list of people who are waiting on
this condition variable then
concurrently one of these threads might
be able to acquire the lock after it's
gotten a vote and then it manipulates
these variables and then it calls
conduct broadcast what that does is it
wakes up whoever's waiting on the
condition variable and so once this
thread unlocks the mutex this one what
do we want as it's returning from wait
we'll reacquire the mutex and then
return to the top of this for loop which
is checking this condition so this
broadcast wakes up whoever's waiting at
this wait and so this avoids having to
have that time dot sleeve for some
arbitrary amount of time like this
thread that's waiting for some condition
to become true only gets woken up when
something changes that might make that
condition become true right like if you
think about these threads if they're
very slow and they don't call conned out
broadcast for a long time this one will
just be waiting it won't be like
periodically waking up and checking some
condition that can't have changed
because nobody else manipulated their
shared data so any questions about this
pattern yeah
so that's a great question I think
you're referring to something called the
lost wake up problem and this is a topic
in operating systems and we won't talk
about it in detail now there feel free
to ask me after lecture but at a high
level you can avoid funny race
conditions that might happen between
wait and broadcast by following the
particular pattern I'm showing here and
I'll show you an abstracted version of
this pattern in a moment basically the
pattern is for the side that might make
changes that will change the outcome of
the condition test you always lock then
manipulate the data then call broadcast
and call unlock afterwards so the
broadcast must be called while holding
the lock similarly when you're checking
the condition you grab the lock then
you're always checking the condition in
a loop and then inside so when that
condition is false you call Condit wait
this is only called while you're holding
the lock and it atomically releases the
lock and kind of schedule like puts
itself in a list of waiting threads and
then as waits returning so as we like
return from this wait call and then go
back to the top of this for loop it will
reacquire the lock so this check will
only happen while holding the lock and
then so outside of this we still have
the lock here and we unlock after we're
done doing whatever we need to do here
at a high level this pattern looks like
this so we have one thread or some
number of threads doing something that
might affect the condition so they're
going to grab a lock do the thing call
broadcast then call unlock and on the
other side we have some thread that's
waiting for some condition to become
true the pattern there it looks like we
grab the lock then in a while loop while
the condition is false we wait and so
then we know that when we get past this
while loop now the condition is true and
we're holding the lock and we can do
whatever we need to do here and then
finally we call unlock so we can talk
about all the things that might go wrong
if you violate one of these rules like
after lecture if you're interested but
at a high level if you follow this
pattern then you won't need to deal with
those issues so any questions about that
yeah
so that's a great question
when do you use broadcast versus when do
use signals so converse have three
methods on them one is wait for the
waiting side and then on the other side
you can use signal or broadcast and the
semantics of those are signal wait wakes
up exactly one waiter like one thread
that may be waiting
whereas broadcast wakes up everybody
who's waiting and they'll all reach out
like they'll all try to grab the law can
recheck the condition and only one of
them will proceed because only one a
little he'll door lock until it gets
past this point I think for the purpose
of this class always use broadcast never
use signal if you follow this pattern
and just like don't use signal and
always use broadcast your code will work
I think you can stick think of signal as
something used for efficiency and we
don't really care about that level of
CPU efficiency in the labs for this
class
any more questions ok so the final topic
we're going to cover in terms of go
concurrency primitives is channels so
two high level channels are like a queue
like synchronization primitive but they
don't behave quite like cues in the
intuitive sense like I think some people
think of channels is like there's this
data structure we can sticks that stick
things in and eventually someone will
pull those things out but in fact
channels have no queuing capacity they
have no internal storage basically
channels are synchronous if you have to
go routines that are going to send and
receive on a channel if someone tries to
send on the channel while nobody's
receiving that thread will block until
somebody's ready to receive and at that
point synchronously it will exchange
that data over to the receiver and the
same is true the other direction if
someone tries to receive from a channel
while nobody's sending that receive will
block until there's another goroutine
that's about to send on the channel and
that send will happen synchronously so
here's a little demo program that
demonstrates this here I have a I
declare channel and then I spawn a go
routine that waits for a second and then
sent and then receives from a channel
and then in my main girl routine I keep
track of the time then I send on the
channel so I just put some dummy data
into the channel and then I'm going to
print out how long the send took
and if you think of channels as cues
with internal storage capacity you might
think of this thing as completing very
fast but that's not how channels work
this send is going to block until this
receive happens and this one happened
till this one second is the elapsed and
so from here to here
we're actually blocked in the main goo
routine for one whole second alright so
don't think of channels as queues think
of them as this synchronous like the
synchronous communication mechanism
another example that'll make this really
obvious is here we have a goroutine that
creates a channel then sends on the
channel and tries receiving from it
doesn't anybody know what'll happen when
I try running this
I think the file name might give it away
yeah exactly the send is going to block
till somebody's ready to receive but
there is no receiver and go actually
detects this condition if all your
threads are sleeping it to text this is
a deadlock condition and it'll actually
crash but you can have more subtle bugs
where if you have some other thread like
off doing something if I spawn this go
routine that you know for loop does
nothing and I try running this program
again now it goes deadlock detector
won't notice that all threads are not
doing any use will work like there's one
thread running it's just this is never
receiving and we can tell by looking at
this program that it'll never terminate
but here it just looks like it hangs so
if you're not careful with channels you
can get these subtle bugs where you have
double X as a result yeah yeah exactly
there's no data nobody's sending on this
channel so this is gonna block here it's
never gonna get to this line
yeah so channels as you pointed out
can't really be used just within a
single goroutine it doesn't really make
sense because in order to send or in
order to receive there has to be another
go routine doing the opposite action at
the same time so if there isn't you're
just gonna block forever and then that
chant but thread will no longer do any
useful work yeah sans wait for receives
receives wait for signs and it happens
synchronously once there's both the
sender and receiver present what I
talked about so far is unbuffered
channels I was going to avoid talking
about buffered channels because there
are very few problems that they're
actually useful for solving so buffered
channels can take in a capacity and then
you can think of it as it's just switch
this to so here's a buffered channel
with a capacity of one this program does
terminate because buffered channels are
like they have some internal storage
space and until that space fills up
sends are non blocking because they can
just put that data in the internal
storage space but once the channel does
fill up then it does behave like a nun
buffer channel in the sense that further
sends will block until there's a receive
to make space in the channel but I think
at a high level we should avoid buffered
channels because they basically don't
solve any problems and another path and
other things should be thinking about is
whenever you to make up arbitrary
numbers like this one here to make your
code work you're probably doing
something wrong yeah
so I think this is a question about
terminology like what exactly does
deadlock mean into this count as a
deadlock like yes this counts as a
deadlock like no useful progress will be
made here like this these threads are
just stuck forever
any other questions so what our channel
is useful for I think channels are
useful for a small set of things like
for example I think for producer
consumer queues sort of situations like
here I have a program that makes a
channel and this spawns a bunch of
goroutines that are going to be doing
some work like say they're competing
some result in producing some data and I
have a bunch of these go routines
running in parallel and I want to
collect all that data as it comes in and
do something with it
so this do work thing just like waits
for a bit and produces a random number
and in the main goroutine I'm going to
continuously receive on this channel and
print it out like this is a great use of
channels another good use of channels is
to achieve something similar to what
wait groups do so rather than use a wait
group suppose I want to spawn a bunch of
threads and wait till they're all done
doing something one way to do that is to
create a channel and then I spawn a
bunch of threads and know how many
threads I've spawned so five goroutines
created here they're going to do
something and then send on this channel
when they're done and then in the main
go routine I can just receive from that
channel the same number of times and
this has the same effect as a wait group
so question so what exactly is the
question
[Music]
so the question is here could you use a
buffered channel with a capacity of five
because you're waiting for five receives
I think in this particular case yes that
would have the equivalent effect but I
think there's not really a reason to do
that
and I think at a high level in your code
you should avoid buffer channels and
also maybe even channels unless you
think very hard about what you're doing
yeah so what is a weight group I think
we covered this in a previous lecture
and I talked about it very briefly today
but I do have an example of weight
groups so a weight group is a yet
another synchronization primitive
provided by go in the sync package and
it kind of does what his name advertises
like it lets you wait for a certain
number of threads to be done the way it
works is you call weight group dot add
and that basically increments some
internal counter and then when you call
weight group dot weight it waits till
done has been called as many times as ad
was called so this code is basically the
same as the code I just showed you that
was using a channel except this is using
weight group they have the exact same
effect you can use either one yeah
so the question here is about race
conditions I think like what happens if
this ad doesn't happen fast enough
before this weight happens or something
like that well so here notice that the
pattern here is we call weight group
data outside of this go routine and it's
called before spawning this go routine
so this happens first this happens next
and so we'll never have the situation
we're done happens after this ad happens
for this particular routine how's this
implemented by the compiler and I will
not talk about that now but talk to me
after class or in office hours but I
think for the purposes class like you
need to know the API for these things
not the implementation all right and so
I think that's basically all I have on
go concurrency primitives so one final
thought is on channels like channels are
good for a specific set of things like I
just showed you the producer consumer
queue or like implementing something
like weight groups but I think when you
try to do fancier things with them like
if you want to say like kick another go
routine that may or may not be waiting
for you to be like woken up that's a
kind of tricky thing to do with channels
there's also a bunch of other ways to
shoot yourself in the foot with them I'm
going to avoid showing you examples of
bad code with channels just because it's
not useful to see but I personally avoid
using channels for the most part and
just use shared memory and mutexes and
condition variables and set and I
personally find those much easier to
reason about so feel free to use
channels for when they make sense but if
anything looks especially awkward to do
with channels like just use mutexes and
condition variables and they're probably
a better tool yeah
so the question is with the difference
between this producer-consumer pattern
here in a thread-safe FIFO I think
they're kind of equivalent like you
could do this with the thread-safe FIFO
and it like that is basically what a
like buffered channel is roughly if
you're in queueing things in Indy
queueing things like if you want this
line to finish and have this thread go
do something else while that data sits
there in a queue rather than this girl
routine waiting to send it then a
buffered channel might make sense but I
think at least in the lives you will not
have a pattern like that all right so
next Fabian's going to talk about more
rapidly related stuff do you need this
all right can you all hear me is this
working yeah all right so yeah basically
I'm going to show you two bugs that we
commonly see in people's raft
implementations there's a lot of bugs
that are pretty common but I'm just
going to focus on two of them so in this
first example we sort of have a start of
a raft implementation for that's sort of
like what you might see for to a just
the beginnings of one
so in our raft state we have primarily
the current status of the raft pier
either follower candidate or leader and
we have these two state variables that
were keeping track of the current term
and who we voted for in the current term
so I'm I want us to focus though on
these two functions attempt election and
call request vote so in a temptin we're
just going to set our state to candidate
increment our current term vote for
ourselves and then start sending out
request votes to all of our raft peers
and so this is similar to some of the
patterns that Anish showed where we're
going to loop through our peers and then
for each one in a go routines separately
call this call request vote function in
order to actually send an RPC to that
peer
alright so in call request vote we're
going to acquire the lock prepare
arguments for our request Ville RPC call
based on by setting it to the current
term and then actually perform the RPC
call over here and finally based on the
response we will reply back to this this
attempt election function and the
attempt election function eventually
should tally up the votes to see if it
got a majority of the votes and can
become leader so what happens when we
run this code so in theory what we might
expect to happen is four so there's
going to be some code that's going to
spawn a few graph spears and actually
try to attempt elections on them and
what should happen are we just start
collecting votes from other peers and
then we're not actually going to tally
them up
but hopefully nothing weird goes wrong
but actually something is going to go
wrong here and we actually activated
goes deadlock detector and somehow we
ran into a deadlock so let's see what
happened for now let's focus on what's
going on with the server zero so server
zero it says it starts attempting an
election at term one that's just
starting the attempt election function
it will acquire the lock set some of the
set some stuff up for performing the
election and then unlock then it's going
to send out a request vote RPC - server
- it finishes processing that request
vote RPC over here so we're just
printing right before and after we
actually send out the RPC and then it
sends out a request vote RPC - server
one but after that it never we never
actually see it finish sending the
request vote RPC so it's actually stuck
in this function call waiting for the
RPC response from server 1 all right now
let's look at what's everyone's doing so
it's it's pretty much the same thing it
sends a request vote I received a server
to that that succeeds it finishes
processing that request vote the
response from server 2 then it sends
this RPC to zero and now what's actually
happening is 0 & 1 are sort of waiting
for the RPC responses from each other
they both sent out an RPC call but not
yet got the response yet and that's
actually sort of the cause of our
deadlock so really what's the reason
that we're dead locking is because we're
holding this lock through our RPC calls
over here in the core requests vote
function we acquire our mutex associated
with our raft peer and we only unlock at
the end of this function so throughout
this entire function we're holding the
lock including when we try to contact
our peer to get the vote and later when
we handle this request vote RPC we
actually only see it at the beginning of
this function in the handler we're also
trying to acquire the lock but we never
actually succeed in acquiring the lock
so just to make this a little bit more
clear the the sort of order of
operations
is happening is in call request vote
server zero is first going to acquire
the lock and send an RPC call to server
one and then simultaneously and
separately server one is going to do the
same thing it's going to enter its call
request vote function acquire the lock
and send this RPC call to server zero
now in server zeros handler and server
ones handler they're trying to acquire
the lock but they can't because they
already are acquiring the lock and
trying to send the RPC call to each
other and that that's actually what's
leading to the deadlock situation so to
solve this basically we want you to not
hold locks through RPC calls and that's
the solution to this problem in fact we
don't need the lock here at all instead
of trying to read the current term when
we enter this call request vote function
we can pass this as an argument here
save the term when we had acquired the
lock earlier in this attempt election
and just passed this as a as a variable
to call request vote so that actually
removes the need to acquire the lock at
all in call request vote alternatively
we could lock while we're preparing the
arguments and then unlock before
actually performing the call and then if
we need to to process the reply we could
lock again afterwards so it's just make
sure to unlock before making it
obviously call and then if you need to
you can acquire the lock again so now if
I save this then so it's still
activating the deadlock detector but
that's actually just because we're not
doing anything at the end but now it's
actually working
we finished sending the request votes on
both sides and all the operations that
we wanted to complete are complete all
right any questions about this example
yeah so not it's sort of so you might
need to use locks when you are preparing
the arguments or processing the response
but yeah you shouldn't hold a lock
through the RPC call while you're
waiting for the other peer to respond
and there's actually another reason to
that in addition to deadlock the other
problem is that in some tests we're
going to sort of have this unreliable
network that could delay some of your
RPC messages potentially by like 50
milliseconds and in that case if you
hold the lock through an RPC call then
any other operation that you try to do
during that 50 milliseconds won't be
able to complete until that RPC response
is received so that that's another issue
that you might run into if you hold the
long so it's both to make things more
efficient and to avoid these potential
deadlock situations
all right so just one more example this
is again using a similar draft
implementation so again in our raft
state we're going to be keeping track of
whether a fuller candidate leader and
then also these two state variables in
this example I want you to focus on this
attempt election function so now we've
first implemented the change that I just
showed you to store the term here and
pass it as a variable to our function
that collects the request votes but
additionally we've implemented some
functionality to add up the votes so
what we'll do is we'll create a local
variable to count the votes and whenever
we get a vote if the vote was not
granted
we'll return immediately from this go
routine where we're processing the boat
otherwise we'll acquire the lock before
editing this shared local variable to
count up the votes and then if we did
not get a majority of the votes will
return immediately otherwise we'll make
ourselves the leader so as with the
other example I mean initially if you
look at this if I look at this like it
seems reasonable but let's see if
anything can go wrong all right so this
is the log output from one run and one
thing you might notice is that we've
actually elected two leaders on the same
term so server zero
it was elected made itself a leader on
term two and server one did as well it's
okay to have a leader elected on
different terms but here where we have
one on the same term that that should
never happen alright so how did this
actually come up so let's start from the
top so at the beginning server zero
actually attempted an election at term
one not turn two and it got its votes
from both of the other peers but for
whatever reason perhaps because those
reply messages from those peers were
delayed it didn't actually process its
process those votes until later and in
between receiving it like in between
attempting the election and finishing
the election server one also decided to
attempt an election perhaps because
because of server zero was delayed so
much server one might
actually ran into the election timeout
and then started its own election and it
started it on term 2 because it couldn't
have been termed 1 because it already
voted for server 0 on on term 1 over
here
okay so then server 1 sends out its own
request votes 2 servers 2 and 0 at term
2 and now we see that server two votes
for server 1 that's fine but server 0
also votes for server 1 this is actually
also fine because server one is asking
server 0 for a vote on a higher term and
so what server 0 should do is if you
remember from the spec it should set its
current term to that term in the request
for RPC message to term 2 and also
revert itself to a follower instead of a
candidate alright finally so the real
problem is that on this line where
server 0 although it really got enough
votes on term 1 it made itself a leader
on term - so the reason so one
explanation for why this is happening is
because in between where we set up the
election our attempt for the election
and where we actually process the votes
some other things are happening input in
this case we're actually voting for
someone else in between and so we're no
longer on term 1 where we thought we
started the election we're now on term 2
and so we just need a double check that
because we don't have the lock while
we're performing the RPC calls which is
important for its own reasons now some
things might have changed and we need to
double check that what we assume is true
when we're setting ourselves to the
leader is still true so one way to solve
this that there's a few different ways
like to solve this like you could
imagine not voting for others while
we're in the middle of attempting an
election but in this case the simplest
way to solve this at least in this
implementation is to just double check
that we're still on the same term and
we're still a candidate we haven't
reverted to a follower so actually one
thing I want to show you is if we do
print out our state over here then we do
see that server 0 became a follower but
it's still setting itself to a leader on
this line
so yeah we can just check for that if
we're not a candidate or the current
term doesn't match the term which we
started the election then let's just
quit and if we do that then
so everyone becomes a leader and we
never cease over zero become leader so
the problem solved any question yeah
yeah I think I think that would I
because we would not if the term is
higher now than actually no it would it
might not be sufficient because we might
have attempted another election it
depends on your implementation but it's
possible that you could have attempted
another election on a higher term
afterwards all we know that's the same
thing right yeah it would not be
sufficient to only check the state but I
think you're right if you only check the
term then it is sufficient all right any
other questions all right so yeah that's
it for this part she's going to show you
some more examples of actually debugging
some of these draft implementations
hi can you all hear me yeah
is it not
okay so in my section I'm gonna walk you
through how I would be but if you have
like a bug in your rough implementation
so I prepare a couple of baccara good
and I just try to walk you through it so
first I'm gonna go into my face
Bucky implementation and if I run the
test here so for this one it doesn't
print anything it just gets started and
it's gonna be here forever and let's
assume that I have no idea why there's
happening
the first thing that I want to find out
is where it gets started and we we do
have a good tool for that which printf
but in the stop code if you go to
youtube go we have a function called the
printf this is just a nice wrapper
around the block cleaners with the
debugger able to enable or disable the
locking messages so I'm gonna enable
that and go back to my graph okay so
first of all when i when when there
there's something that's but happening I
always go check if the code actually
actually initialize graph server so here
I'll just clean
okay so here if I run the test again
then now I know that there are three
servers that God he initialized so this
files is okay but like there's nowhere
where the bow is happening so I'll just
go deeper into the hood just to find
where it gets stuck so now if you see
the code we are calling the leader a
tech election so I'm gonna go to that
function and just to make faster I'll
try to check if it kicks off some
iteration
that part still fine so we we try to go
for now here we are in the election I'll
see if there's so we actually send the
request voice to some other servers
now we kind of have like more idea of
where guests are because it's not
printing that some sorry that kicks off
the election are not sending the request
words so I would go back for her just to
see where customers like I always tried
here prin if if we call some function
aye-aye
I was always double shake if it actually
go into the function so now I'm going to
say that this service is at the start of
the election
and that works so now we have an idea of
like the box should be between here and
here so we are trying to minimize the
scope of the code that's causing the bug
let's say if I pin something here
and it does it doesn't get there so I
move it up let's say here still not
there
now it's there so the bug is probably in
this function and I just go check so
here the problem is that I'm trying to
acquire a lock where I actually do have
the lock so it's gonna be a day long so
that's how I will find their first bug
using the D printers and it's it's nice
to use the printf because you can like
just turn off the debugging print and
have a nice test output with our audit
debugging if you want it so that's how I
would use it deep enough to try to like
handle a bug in your code and for this
example there's actually another trick
to help you find this kind of deadlock
so if you press ctrl + backslash you can
see in the bottle but bottom left that I
press like control and backslash this
this command will send a signal quit
today
go program and by default it will
handles the the quiz signal and quit all
the go routines and print audio strike
the stack rates so now this like Chico
up here like this way it gets touched
and then there are gonna be a couple
functions printing here
just trying to go through all the traces
yes so it's actually showing that the
function that's causing the problem is
the cover to candidate so that's another
weight you've to find out where the day
locks are I can remove all this
and now it works so that's the first
example that I want to go through second
thing that you want it you want to do
before you submit your labs is to turn
the race
flag on when you do the test the way to
do that is just to add - race before
- groin and here because my implement
implementation doesn't have any research
so it's not going to tell you anything
but this just be careful about this
because it's not a proof that you don't
have any really it's just that it cannot
detect races for you I'm going to run
the same command again with the red flag
but now this time that's actually risk
going on in my implementation so it's
gonna yell at you that there's some
deliveries going on in your code
I'm quitting that and let's see like how
useful is the warning are so I'm gonna
go to my second implementation with
Rothko and here
let's look at this race so it's telling
us that there's a wheat going on at the
line
103 I'm going to that line so this the
wheat on probably Thursday here and
there's also a right line for 12 which
is Thursday so
I'm going to this line again
and now we kind of know that this this
radiation is protected by a lock so the
risk flies actually wanting us and
helping us to find out but on on this
database that we have so the fake it's
gonna be just you lock this and unlock
it and that should solve the problem
so at this place we kind of know how to
basic like do some basic debugging does
anyone have any question no okay yeah so
I'm going to go to the third one which
is going to be more difficult to find
about I'm going to test the run the
centers and now I am I actually have
some debugging messages in there already
and just see that I also have a
debugging message with the test action
there's something you might want to
consider doing if you go into the test
clip here
you can just see how the test would run
and then there are some actions that the
test clip is gonna do to make your code
fail and it's usually a good idea to
print out where that action is happening
in your actual debugging message so you
can guess what is happening like where
the bug is happening in which phase of
the test if that make sense so now it's
like I was doing fine in the first case
I passed I passed the fail but I'm
failing their second tiers and here the
Test section is to found one as a little
one so I'm passing this the test until
this and if you go to I'm actually
passing until the leader two rejoins so
this can give you a nice idea of how the
test is working and just to help you
have a better case as where the bondage
is in your code so now let's look at the
debugging messages
so it's least it seems like when liturgy
we joined it becomes a follower and we
have a new leader
so that looks fine to me and we probably
need more debugging messages instead of
just their state changes so I am going
to add some more my first case that when
one becomes a leader it might not be
doing what a leader should you correctly
so we got stuck
so you might could after we cover it as
eventually there I have a go routine
call operate leader
there's just standing habit CD all set
to the audio servers so I'm gonna print
some stuff here saying happy - cheers
away
so to become solidary it sends the the
first happy to each server and one still
tries to send happy to the new leader
and then one becomes a follower so this
doesn't look like to be a problem now
I'm gonna check if the other service
receive habit correctly
it's taking away with I'm trying to
finish this yeah so to becomes a leader
to sends high bid but no one receive a
habit form - so if I go to the same
opinion tree I actually hold the law to
the RPC Hall which is the problem that
Fabian went to in the last section so
that's that's the problem that I need to
fix so what I should do is to a lot here
and then
lock again here and that should work
we pass and then there are couple things
that you might want to do when you test
your rough implementation so that's
actually script to run the test in
imperial and I can show you how I how we
can use how we can use it this creep is
in the inner peer support some someone
make a point about it and here's how we
can use the script so you run the script
specify the number of the test
personally I do like a 1000 but that
depends on your preference this is the
number of course that you wanna run the
test at the same time and then here's
the test and if you run the script then
if you show you that's like we have run
four tests so far all are working fine
and it's gonna keep going like that so
that's how I would go about debugging
rough implementation and you are all
welcome to come to office hours when you
need help